- It's super frustrating when people don't
have any idea as to what
they're applying for.
(upbeat music)
I'm a recruiter.
- I've been recruiting in New
York City for about six years.
- And this is what you
need to know to get hired.
- When we get a resume,
we get super excited.
I've got a great position open.
My VP comes to me and he goes
oh my God, this is the guy.
We have contacts at said companies
that this person has worked at.
Come to find out, this
person never worked there.
- Someone told us that they graduated
with a Bachelor's Degree.
We ended up doing a background check.
It came back that they
didn't go to college at all,
and we had to rescind the offer.
- Don't lie (laughs).
- First off, a resume
should always be one page.
- I always recommend that your resume
should not be longer than two pages.
- The most important
information on the top, right?
Things that you're most proud about,
and then what's your work experience.
- When I see fonts like
Comic Sans, Wingdings,
any sort of weird formatting
symbolism in your resume,
I am probably not going
to move you forward.
- The worst ones are ones that either
are way too complicated and
have too much information
that has nothing to do
with what I'm looking for
or they're too simplified.
- I literally got a resume once that said
I don't need a resume, my
background will speak for itself,
call me, and they did not get the job.
- The worst phone calls are
when you get on the phone,
why'd you apply?
What do you know about my company?
And you have nothing.
- Absolutely do your
research, it's so important.
Get on GlassDoor, get on their website.
- If you're sick, do not
come in to a job interview.
There was this one time I
was confirming an interview
and they told me, they were
like okay, I have pink eye.
I'm gonna wear an eye patch.
I hope that's okay.
Totally okay.
She ended up coming in, and
she didn't wear an eye patch.
Just call out, just stay home.
Don't come in with pink eye.
- I work in an office that is...
I'll call it business comfortable.
I want you to represent that.
I want you to feel like
you could slide in,
and that's what we're
looking for, visually.
- I would probably research
and go onto the LinkedIn page
and the company's page
to see how they dress.
- If we're super casual
and you're coming in
with a three piece suit,
probably not gonna work out.
- It is too damn much.
Don't do that, don't do that.
- When we ask about
your greatest weakness,
usually I'm just asking to see
how honest you are with yourself.
Things that will help me
understand that you are generally
paying attention to who
your inner person is.
That's important to hear.
- A good answer for your
weakness should be genuine.
What is an actual weakness
that you wanna work on,
and tell us how and why.
- So, for example,
if your greatness weakness is
that you can't get up on time,
you should finish your answer
by saying that's my weakness,
but this is what I'm doing to work on it.
- The first conversation
I have with candidates
is always about money.
- There is a line, right?
There's a cap, and then there's a floor.
- If you want 20 grand
more than the job offers,
then that's a conversation you should have
from the very beginning so
there's full transparency
between all parties.
- You're not getting underpaid, right?
So, imagine a tree.
You might fit in the middle, right?
And if that middle, let's
just call it $50,000,
I can't give you $30,000
because I think I can negotiate you there
because the people that
you're gonna be sitting across
and beside, they all make $50,000.
So, if you tell me you need $100,000,
I'm gonna go, it's not gonna work
'cause I know what
everyone else is making.
I need you to fit kind of
in a similar bucket, right?
- Make sure you have at
least three questions
at the end of your conversation
to ask the recruiter.
- I think a really good question
to ask at the end of an interview
is what can I do in this role
in the first three
months to be successful?
- What does the first 30 to
90 days look like in this job?
- I think that gives you
the perfect framework
for what you can do in the future.
If you get the job,
you'll basically have a cheat sheet
for what you need to do in
your first couple months.
- If you don't get the job,
don't stalk me, it's over.
- The stalker scenario is when a candidate
does not understand why
they didn't get the job
and they follow you on Instagram,
they follow you on Facebook.
- I definitely had a guy, and
this guy could not let it go.
He showed up to the office
wanting to talk to me.
- A connection on LinkedIn,
fine, that's cool, but that's...
Anything more than that,
you crossed the line.
- I get not a Facebook message,
not an Instagram message,
he messages me on LinkedIn
and asks me out on a date
after we turned him down for an interview.
He did not get the job,
and he definitely did not get the date.
Keep reaching out to people on LinkedIn,
keep expanding your network.
There is a job out there for you.
(upbeat music)